Graphs can be functionally the same but
built in a handful of different ways.
If you're using an object oriented
language you could create vertex and
edge objects and
give them each properties like name,
strength, ID number, etc.
A vertex could have a list of edges
it's connected to and vice versa.
However, operations that traverse
graphs can be more inconvenient
if you need to search through vertex and
edge objects.
There are several ways to represent
connections on simple graphs
that only use lists.
One example is an edge list,
which is precisely what you'd think,
it's simply a list of edges.
The edges themselves are represented
by a list of two elements.
Those elements are normally numbers that
correspond to ID numbers for vertices.
So, in the end,
this list is just showing two nodes
that have an edge between them.
And an edge list is the list that
encompasses all the smaller lists.
Because our edge list contains
a list of other lists,
it's sometimes called a two
dimensional list, or a 2D list.
If you had a list of lists of lists,
that would be called a 3D list,
and so on.
An adjacency list is another way
to represent edges in a graph.
In an adjacency list, your vertices
normally have an ID number that
corresponds to the index in an array.
In your array, each space is
used to store a list of nodes
that the node with our ID is adjacent to.
For example, the opening at index 0
represents a vertex with an ID of 0.
That vertex shares
an edge with one node, so
a reference to that node is stored
in the first spot in the array.
Again, our adjacency
list is two dimensional,
since it's a list that
contains other lists.